NARRATOR: If tiger
sharks are showing up
in the shallows in
greater numbers,
then it's not
because of deep blue.
The reason for the
attacks remains elusive.
But while scouring the
ocean for an explanation,
experts come across
something else
that also ensnares large
amounts of a tiger shark's prey.
But it's not another
sea creature.
In fact, it walks on two legs.
NAIA RAE FOX: I think the reason
why we are having more sharks
here actually is because
the amount of fishing
that's been going on.
NARRATOR: This is one of
the island's most popular
activities, sport fishing.
Every year, recreational
anglers haul in more
than 2 million pounds of fish.
That means that on any given
day off the big island,
there are hundreds of fish
being caught and reeled in.
And for scientists
like Dr. Dan Huber,
these hooked sea creatures
may be attracting sharks.
DAN HUBLER: A struggling
fish, as its body
is twitching a bit,
that motion is giving
off low frequency sounds.
And shark hearing
happens to be tuned
into low frequency sounds.
This is definitely something
that could attract a number
of sharks to the same area.
NARRATOR: So could sport
fishing be drawing tiger sharks
into the shallows,
thereby increasing
the risk of an accidental
run in with people?
According to
fisherman Rick Rieger,
it comes down to where the
best sport fishing takes place.
To demonstrate, he heads
out to an area well
known for the popular pastime.
RICK RIEGER: So this
is our bottom here.
We have some of the
steepest drop offs
in the whole world right here.
This is where you're going to
see your tuna, your mahi-mahi,
your ono, your marlin.
NARRATOR: This location
could hold a vital clue
to solving the mystery.
Called the pelagic
zone, this open water
abyss extends thousands
of miles between
the continental shelves.
It's home to an array
of large sea creatures--
whales, manta rays, big game
fish, and some of the most
dangerous sharks on earth.